on the slopes of Africa's biggest
mountain Kilimanjaro the search is on to
find its tallest tree the journey takes
in rain forests and rivers and a
near-vertical mud bank but the
destination makes it worth it until now
this 600 year old mahogany was the
mountains best-kept secret at 81 meters
it is Africa's tallest recorded tree
most of these Tanzanians are seen it for
the first time an exciting experience as
they explain at what might just be the
country's most remote press conference
I'm happy and also I'm happy for my
country
to have such a good thing what do you
think of it no it's great after all it
will open doors for tourism to cream and
jar oh yeah therefore we have two
wonders in Kilimanjaro their highest
mountain in Africa which is cream and
Aaron Tveit tallest tree mere figure it
was found by German botanist Andreas
hemp he's been studying Kilimanjaro for
nearly 30 years he was first struck by
the height to the tree 20 years ago but
it was only recently that it was able to
measure it
oh this is my chance we didn't look for
for toiletries we made a vegetation
survey a forest survey and then we
measured our plots all treason or plots
we have over 30 forest plots here on the
mountain and by chance we detected that
we have the tallest here at econo plots
the forest faces the same threat is all
of Tanzania's forests logging by
communities that need firewood even huge
mahogany's frequently end up felled
hamp and his research team are trying to
educate people to look after the forest
Nina this gives us an economist and
I love the discovery of Africa's tallest
tree may help change things the
researchers hope it will raise awareness
of the rainforest beauty that might help
secure funding to protect it in a way I
mean we knew of this important little
patch but now since the tallest tree is
found I think we have a chance and
because you get attention now as you see
with your team and this yeah makes us
happy I mean I think the chance is quite
good that so easy anymore coming inside
this gorge and cutting Peter matcha is a
village leader who lives in the valley
he's worked with conservationists to
stop illegal logging but like many he
works hard for a meager livelihood
he says illegal loggers have made life
worse for everyone because now there is
a total ban on logging naku naku naku
naku naku permit at ease
to be honest it does cause other
problems not being able to cut trees for
example if I want to finish building my
home I can't actually afford to go and
buy wood the fan now but the illegal
loggers are to blame they cut too many
trees down and they do it for commercial
purpose you know even so now none of us
can open a Papa Zita not Apache damara
in Guinea
local politicians have pledged to
improve forest protection while
supporting local communities they're
also keen to maximize the tourism
potential of the forest - in the long
term the recent discovery of Africa's
tallest tree will hopefully ensure
younger trees will one day reach similar
heights